right yeah obviously this last few years
has been kind of interesting because of
rickrolling and the things that have
happened on the internet so that's but I
mean she was probably about 15 I think
something like that when when that
happened 15 16 and we had good talks
about it she kind of because she's of
that generation she could see it with
different eyes and even though it was
her dad she could see it and say look it
doesn't got anything to do with you
just let it just let it go just let it
go over your head because it's it don't
get involved don't try and use it don't
and I have no intentions of but I think
she confirmed that for me so it's kind
of Handy really to have somebody of that
age to be able to talk to who who had my
best interests at heart
and maybe her own as well but she's been
amazing she's been amazing to be honest
it's been like I say I think you can
learn somebody from any age definitely
but I think I think when it's your
daughter it's a very different thing
because it's a different dynamic the
last thing I wanted to do is embarrass
her an avid kind of feel like oh you
know what I mean and so it was kind of
great that we could have conversations
about it really well you think your
reaction to the whole different I think
it might have if I'm honest yet because
well I would have spots friends kids I
guess hopefully they would Ian and I
mean but actually having somebody who
was 1516 somebody who would have been in
that kind of world of kind of living
more on the internet that I certainly
was and even to this day do I think that
perspective was really helpful
definitely like I say it it can never be
just a normal situation because her
dad's the Rickon rickrolling
and that's a bit weird I think it must
be for her but she's just been great
she's just kind of like takes it in
Australia really you know
she's really proud of me and she likes
the new stuff she you know she's been to
a few gigs I think she having an again
she'll just sent me a little whatever a
little message and just kind of say that
she's proud of me and I do that with her
you know she's studying art and she
lives in Copenhagen which is where my
wife is from my mom obviously and and
yeah I think there's a good we have a
good kind of mutual appreciation of both
what we do I think because I understand
it's difficult I think her mom my wife
is a film producer so I think it's quite
difficult to have been in that house and
grown up in that house and then decide
well I don't want to do any of those
things I want to do this but I still
want to create and I want to be creative
and I think sometimes you can see that
in kids of famous or successful or
whatever parents who've had a bit of a
career going that you know I think
sometimes it's difficult cuz it's hard
to find out what you want to do and
people will always say if you go into
music and your mom are you dabble in
music I'll say oh well you got into it
you know the easy way because during the
mean and I think sometimes it's it's
harder if your parents were in music or
film or whatever it is that you know I
mean it's it's a tough one you can never
win I think in that position so also
you're not just putting a musical ticket
number one yeah which was amazing
absolutely incredible when I set out to
make the record I was doing it as I say
because fans had encouraged me to and
also because I wanted to mark my
birthday and I want to just make some
music and say look that's what I can do
at this agent I'm a life this time on my
life and I think when I've done a few of
the tracks and finished them I kind of
felt they were perhaps better than I was
expecting and I played them to a few
friends